is something to keep in mind as things
heat up State lawmakers introducing a
bill seeking to protect outdoor workers
from our brutal summer Mary Jane beliesa
looking into this today joining us live
now MJ I know it's warm out there right
now but we all know the Heat's coming
right
tell me about it you know I've only been
out here for
Vegas that's why those in support of SB
427 say it's that much more important to
protect our outdoor workers
employees at boss security screens put
in the time and effort to install
security screens that protect homeowners
from Intruders
it's a job full of hard labor which is
why Chief Operating Officer Elena Ledoux
works that much harder to protect her
employees from hot temperatures and that
starts at the hiring process we actually
give ample notice of him or please
prospective candidates that we this
position requires a lot of working
Outdoors this also means working early
hours to avoid the Sun and clocking out
by 2PM the latest it's critical we do
provide uniform that that's long sleeves
and that's cotton it's not synthetic
just so it's easier you know on the body
and the heat we do provide cold drinks
we provide ice packs while Ladue already
has heat safety rules in place for the
company she's happy to hear lawmakers
are taking extra precautions to protect
outdoor workers Cynthia Moore the
coordinator from the Nevada
environmental justice Coalition says
sb427 would set the definition of
extreme heat at 105 degrees we're
working really closely with our bill
sponsor Senator Flores we came to him
with the idea for this bill and because
he he represents an area where a lot of
his constituents work outdoors and work
in these conditions he was a huge
supporter of making this happen sb427
also requires shade and water breaks and
employers must provide proper Mass
during bad air quality I truly applaud
our construction workers our other
workers that work in Industries where
they have to work Outdoors because they
really because of them it's what keeps
our our city going
now the bill would also train employees
to look for signs of heat related
illnesses and how to respond and more
tells me while Nevada OSHA already has
standard Protections in place this bill
will just help further protect those
employees working outside reporting live
Mary Jane vallessa 8 News Now